friend's lack of diversity embarrassed
its co-creator
what do you know so she made a four
million dollar decision
very very dramatic
so this is marta kathman she was
co-founder of friends along with david
crane
for people who know the show well and
this is what what the article says let's
do a little reading
despite its success the comedy was
repeatedly criticized for its lack of
diversity
by whom
buy home media critics
were you sitting at home watching
friends thinking well i don't know to me
i can't i can't enjoy this comedy
because i don't see diversity in the
cast no because that's not how sane
people view the world they don't view
the world through color
of your skin and your gen they just want
to watch a comedy and have a few laughs
after work they're not thinking that
hard about this stuff every second of
every minute of every day like they want
you to right
well marta got to thinking
she got some feedback from her
associates and it says
essentially numerous observers whatever
it was probably like five people in the
media industry were wondering how the
characters existed in a predominantly
white environment even though the series
was set in new york city well it's a tv
show
it's just a tv show
not everything needs to be so serious
it's a comedy to boot
kaufman felt friends was being unfairly
singled out claiming there was too much
attention on the near absence of black
people and other people of color it was
difficult and frustrating but now
kaufman says she gets it okay so she
didn't get it before but now
now she gets it
this is what she says
the series failure to be more inclusive
was a symptom of her internalization of
the systemic racism
that plagues our society
she internalized that and hence did not
diversify the caste
you can't make this stuff up
which she came to see more clearly by
the way in the aftermath of the 2020
murder of george floyd by minneapolis
police and the worldwide protest
movement that erupted
as a result she decided she was going to
put four million dollars to her alma
mater the boston areas brandeis
university to establish an endowed
professorship in the school's african
and african american studies this is my
favorite part the quote i've learned a
lot in the last 20 years admitting and
accepting guilt
is not easy it's painful looking at
yourself in the mirror i mean i like if
there were vomit emojis that i could put
all over the screen right now that's
what you'd see
not everything needs to be analyzed and
over analyzed not everything not
everyone views everything through the
lens of race and oh my god there needs
to be you know what there were no asian
people there was what was it uh ross's
girlfriend and you know what they made a
bunch of jokes about that
they made jokes about that and it was
okay because it was a comedy and it was
funny and that's what we're supposed to
do laugh at ourselves i'm italian i
laugh at myself all day long i have a
crazy italian accent i have a crazy
italian family please make fun of me
or life would be so boring
not everybody looked at these shows and
analyzed them this way i realize it's
not cool to not just say to say oh well
it's just a comedy like enjoy it but
this is ridiculous
this is getting ridiculous and as i got
to thinking about it i also got to
thinking of the content of friends which
would never survive now
you could not make that show today and i
started thinking of all the topics do
you guys remember the episode where joey
has the bag the leather bag and they're
calling him a woman and they're like you
look like a girl forget that
maybe he identifies as a woman and we
need to take that seriously i mean it's
ridiculous
how about chandler's dad
who is the drag queen
that they make fun of all the time it's
funny as all hell
can't do that i made a list of these too
because i was like it was like every
time i turned around there was another
gay jokes how many gay jokes they make
it's funny
it's just comedy it's not it's not about
oh my god my injured feelings you're
supposed to laugh at yourself
and then we talked about the episode
with the toy the other day where ross
wants his kid to play with the gi joe
but he plays with the barbie ben i mean
it was almost like as i started how
about the male nanny you guys remember
that episode with the male nanny
and ross doesn't want the male nanny
because it's like he's like are you gay
and it's a whole big thing
you would basically have to gut the
entire show and you'd also have to gut
every other show anybody ever see an
episode of married with children
okay if you're really young go back and
try to find one literally everything in
hate when people say literally i gotta
catch myself on that tyler every time i
say literally somebody needs to hit a
button
it's like a shock collar
stop jed
you couldn't watch any of these shows in
peace because you'd have to sit now
you'd have to look at the show and you'd
have to say well first of all none of
these jokes
are good because they're all going to
make somebody out there uncomfortable so
delete
then you'd have to look at the cast and
be like well there's not enough i mean
the gender disparity here is just
unheard of it's uncanny
then you'd have to make sure that every
race was represented i mean honestly who
even wants to live in this time with the
way it's going
you wonder why i want to get into
delorean do you really have to think
about it if you really look at society
now and the total neurosis that's
overtaking everything
so listen i don't know what to tell her
i don't know what to tell marta i don't
know if she legitimately feels this way
or she has so much pressure from
colleagues that she needs to come out
and make a statement and a donation i
don't know i really hope it's the latter
because that would just be a sign of a
weak person not someone that had
completely lost their minds these shows
existed in a different time okay
appreciate them for what they were
they're not going to be perfect we're
never going to be perfect and you know
what a joke's going to offend you every
now and then it's called growing a
backbone
go to a bunch of comedy shows you'll
grow on real fast if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]